[Musica]
mi chiamo alessandro de marco sono nato
nel 2000 e sono cresciuto insieme ad
internet da piccolo avevo le idee non
troppo chiare ho cambiato il mio lavoro
dei sogni tantissime volte fino a quando
ho capito e ho capito che volevo fare il
programmatore di computer
una volta pensate il programmatore di
computer era elencato tra i lavori più
in attacco bili sulla terra hanno
scritto i codici per dare vita alle
macchine che hanno cambiato il mondo
avevo 10 anni quando ero certo che
quella era la mia strada
dovete sapere però che un proverbio
cinese dice lo sciocco a mille certezze
il saggio non ne ha alcuna
a 10 anni era uno sciocco
era uno sciocco perché se avessi seguito
quella strada probabilmente oggi starei
per terminare gli studi più inutili che
avrei potuto fare
secondo una ricerca dell'istituto
italiano di futurologia futuro prossimo
infatti oggi quasi nessuno cerca più
questa figura sul mercato
questo è un esempio che vi posso portare
su come oggi il mondo sia veloce nei
cambiamenti e ad esempio nel 2000 se io
vi avessi detto che internet sarebbe
diventato un mezzo
da cui trarre un guadagno in pochissimi
arresti creduto
eppure nel 2005 nasce youtube
oggi ci sono tantissime persone che
guadagnano e vivono grazie a youtube
questo ci deve mettere davanti alla
l'idea di avere una mentalità flessibile
ed essere sempre preparati a un
cambiamento
l'esempio degli influencer è il migliore
che posso farvi per cercare di farvi
capire quello che vi voglio dire
l'influenza è un lavoro che sentiamo da
poco
pochi anni ma al giorno d'oggi è davvero
molto remunerativo secondo una stima di
forbes un canale youtube di cinque amici
nel 2020 in solo un anno ha guadagnato
23 milioni di dollari 23 milioni di
dollari caricando solamente video su
youtube
c è un lavoro molto remunerativo ma
siamo sicuri che durerà nel tempo
secondo un report della mckinsey global
institute infatti
circa 100 milioni di lavoratori da qui
al 2030 vedranno il loro lavoro cambiare
completamente
ma se il 2030 non vi sembra poi così
vicino dovete sapere che è emerso dal
forum sul futuro del lavoro e delle
nuove competenze organizzato dal sole 24
ore che il 50 60 per cento dei
lavoratori vedrà cambiare le proprie
attività nei prossimi cinque anni
questo ancora per dimostrarvi che
dovremmo avere una mentalità sempre più
aperta e sempre piu flessibile
i ragazzini che se stante parlando oggi
alla scuola primaria due terzi di loro
dovete pensare che si sta preparando per
andare a fare un lavoro che oggi non
esiste o ancora la vita media di alcune
competenze ingegneristiche
oggi vede la sua durata
andare a picco
stiamo parlando di due anni e mezzo
cinque anni
questo ancora una volta e per farvi
capire la flessibilità che dobbiamo
avere è qui l'unica nostra soluzione che
può essere è una formazione continua
nelson mandela disse l'istruzione è
l'arma per cambiare il mondo ma secondo
me oggi l'istruzione è anche l'unica
arma che abbiamo per
seguire i cambiamenti del mondo
quando
dieci anni avevo in mente di fare il
programmatore di computer
poi nei piani sono sono cambiati oggi
sono uno sviluppatore quindi mi occupo
di siti web app e altro
e durante le vacanze estive di quando
andavo alle superiori
volevo trovare un progetto a cui
dedicarmi per poter definire che la
strada dello sviluppatore era quello che
volevo fare
forse per l'età forse perché non avevo
ancora una laurea ma nessuno medie da
questa possibilità così con un amico
decidemmo all'età di 16 anni di avviare
un progetto da soli il progetto andò
benissimo
ci regala delle emozioni indescrivibili
ma soprattutto competenze
sono arrivato poi al quinto anno delle
scuole superiori e purtroppo il mio
tempo lo dovevo dedicare totalmente allo
studio quindi ho dovuto prendere la
scelta molto sofferta di dover
abbandonare il mio progetto
questo però mi ha insegnato che non
bisogna mai sedersi sulla convinzione
che tutto vada bene ora e quindi andrà
bene per sempre perché il mondo in
pochissimo cambia come è successo se ci
pensate ai ristoratori magari avevano
dei progetti magari avevano in mente un
futuro per il loro locale è invece il
loro locale è stato chiuso perché siamo
andati in lockdown
anche qui grazie delle mie competenze
sono riuscito ad aiutarvi e all avviato
un progetto per aiutarli a riprendersi a
superare i momenti di difficoltà che
hanno avuto eco qualcuno sta ancora
avendo oggi
dobbiamo
arrivare ad avere un pensiero
totalmente flessibile
perché io se non avessi avuto delle
persone che mi consigliavano il progetto
di cui vi sto parlando sarebbe terminato
un mese dopo l'inizio
veniamo da un epoca in cui
lavorativamente parlando la nostra
massima aspirazione era arrivare a un
posto fisso ed eravamo abitudinari
perché andiamo sempre negli stessi
ristoranti o al mare sempre nello stesso
posto ma dobbiamo prepararci
a una flessibilità
il mio progetto che aiuta ristoratori di
cui vi ho parlato poco fa
come vi dicevo non avrebbe aiutato
nessuno se non grazie all'ascolto delle
idee dopo i primi clienti ho capito che
quello che offrivamo ovvero
digitalizzare i loro menù per abbattere
i rischi di contagio del covip non era
sufficiente
a loro servivano delle persone che
prendesse tutto ciò che era la loro
parte online quindi ho dovuto modificare
il progetto fare un passo avanti e
andare così a inserire nel team delle
persone che si occupassero di gestire il
loro social network e di gestire i loro
programmi di business
siamo arrivati al momento in cui si è
creata una situazione bellissima in
pratica il team di sviluppatori era
aiutato dal team del marketing per
creare un sistema che andasse ad aiutare
i nostri clienti nel posizionamento
online
in pratica se io mi trovo in una città
d'italia e scrivo in nome di un
ristorante di pesce i nostri clienti
appaiono per primi
questa è una mano che siamo riusciti a
dare ai ristoratori ma soprattutto è la
dimostrazione che in tutti i nostri
business dobbiamo sempre essere pronti a
cambiare qualcosa
la formazione continua di cui vi parlavo
poco fa
servirà anche perché quando tra pochi
anni un datore di lavoro sarà indeciso
se assumere noi o comprare un computer
che fa il nostro lavoro
dovremo giocarci sulla nostra capacità
di adattamento perché il computer e una
volta che è stato programmato errori non
li fa noi qualche volta sbagliamo e
quindi possiamo vincere questa battaglia
solamente se riusciamo ad essere
adattabili
dobbiamo riuscire ad avere una
competenza
massima e molto verticale su quello che
il nostro settore avere una formazione
continua ad essere altamente qualificati
nel nostro il settore sono le chiavi che
ci permetteranno di vincere le battaglie
contro i robot e contro i computer
avere un pensiero una mentalità
flessibile sarà fondamentale
soprattutto sarà fondamentale riuscire a
prevedere ogni cambiamento perché i
cambiamenti di cui vi parlo sono i
cambiamenti che hanno portato
all'estinzione lavori come i
programmatori di computer
io mi chiamo alessandro de marco ho 21
anni e da piccolo sognavo di fare un
lavoro che oggi non esiste più
[Applauso]
[Musica]